philippe murray répond namyst bonjour et
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france la banque centrale d'angleterre
va donc financer a directement les
dépenses du gouvernement britannique lié
aux conséquences de la crise sanitaire
concrètement pour qu'on comprenne bien
qu'est ce que cela signifie en fait ça
signifie que on met en place la planche
à billets en angleterre que la banque
d'angleterre va imprimer des billets et
va les remettre au gouvernement
britannique et à partir son homologue le
gouvernement britannique va pouvoir
dépenser pour sauver des vies ou aussi
sauver des entreprises de la destruction
qui créerait des problèmes
évidemment majeur donc en fait là le
royaume uni se passe des banques et des
marchés financiers et donc indirectement
de leur pouvoir sur l'état c'est pour ça
que c'est important et c'est un tabou
comme vous l'avez dit puisque avant
l'angleterre emprunter aux banques
l'institut les bars dont les banques
emprunter à la banque centrale
d'angleterre qui est une institution
publique pour re prêter immédiatement à
ce moment là aux halles et en anglais en
faisant une marche et en capturant donc
non seulement ils marchent mais aussi un
pouvoir d'influencé du loup le pouvoir
que les citoyens ordinaires
comprenez que qu'avaient les marchés
financiers et les banques ce pouvoir
excessif
est ce qu'on peut voir aussi cette
démarche comme la première prise
d'indépendance du royaume uni vis-à-vis
de la bce dopu break site
d'une certaine manière oui mais c'est
surtout le pragmatisme britannique qui
qui s'exprime ici
alors que nous nous restons
effectivement plutôt dans le dogmatisme
de l'union européenne puisque la france
avait le droit d'emprunter directement à
la banque centrale à la banque de france
jusqu'en 1973 une loi l'interdît pour
préparer d'ailleurs l'avènement de la
monnaie unique de l'euro qui se
préparait déjà
or dans l'euro en fait qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est exactement l'inversé c'est à
dire qu'en fait la banque centrale
européenne qui est une organisation
publique déverse 1000 milliards d'euros
sur les marchés financiers va acheté
1000 milliards d'euros d'actifs faire
monter les marchés financiers pour que
l'état puisse y retrouver ainsi ça
paraît pas très différent mais s'il ya
une différence fondamentale quand même
c'est le fait que dans un cas on relance
l'économie et toute la société par la
finance c'est le cas de l'union
européenne et dans le cas
et annick ont dit on va recommande
relancer l'économie mais par l'économie
réelle
voilà une différence de taille mais
alors pour quelles raisons à ce que
cette démarche britannique est synonyme
pour certains de dépenses incontrôlées
non je ne pense pas du tout de toute
manière la banque centrale européenne
vient de dépenser 1000 milliards d'euros
d'argent public qu'elle qu'elle met dans
les marchés financiers donc on est là
sur des sommes qui sont absolument
gigantesque alors en revanche il ya une
chose qui est clair c'est que c'est un
tabou total pour les pour les allemands
qui en diront toujours du mal puisque
faire ça pour eux c'est diabolique
alors effectivement il faut dire qu'il
faut des limites à cela quand même c'est
à dire que ton qu'on aimait de la
monnaie avec un cadre clair c'est à dire
que cette monnaie doit être créé pour
être mise en phase de travail donc c'est
une monnaie qui est créé pour des
investissements ou pour une mesure de
sauvegarde ultime comme cela tout se
passe bien
par contre si on commence à faire de
l'hélicoptère monnaie c'est à dire de
donner de l'argent aux gens sur leur
compte bancaire pour qu'il dépense en
achetant d'ailleurs des produits chinois
tout le monde comprendra que ça peut
conduire à la ruine
mais dans le dans le cadre anglais je
pense qu'il faut pas avoir des angoisses
là dessus et toute manière il faut
mettre tout l'argent nécessaire pour
sauver des vies et surtout et aussi
sauvé toute l'économie sinon daurade et
destruction irréversible d'entreprise de
moyens de production et d'un mot est ce
que vous pensez que ce qu'elle puisse
permettre un à londres de rebondir
économiquement plus rapidement que ses
ex partenaires européens
ah oui tout à fait tout à fait parce que
la france est un peu malheureusement en
lui dans l'union européenne on le sait
et nous au contraire le mécanisme a été
mis cette passer par les marchés
financiers et donc passer par leurs
fourches caudines est aussi le passé par
le mécanisme européen de stabilité
c'est le grand plan entre guillemets de
solidarité européenne or passer par le
mess pour emprunter c'est ce qu'a
proposé beaucoup de la mer ça signifiera
passer sous la conditionnalité du mess
et donc comme la grèce passait sous des
programmes économiques d'ajustement qui
ont ruiné la grèce je pense que c'est
assez dangereux et d'ailleurs c'est ce
que dit le medef quand il dit il faudra
travailler plus plus d'heures pour
chacun moins de droit du travail
l'angleterre et boris johnson
choisissent le cas inverse puisque non
seulement ils ont fait ça mais ils ont
aussi augmenté de 6%
le smic en mars et il augmente le
programme de santé publique en mettant
30 milliards sur la table mais bien
avant la crise du coronavirus pour les
hôpitaux britanniques
ils sont en train de complètement de
changer de modèle il sorte de l'économie
néolibérale pour passer à tout autre
chose
alors que la france reste engluée dans
ce modèle qui ne marche pas merci
beaucoup pour votre analyse philippe
muray rares islamistes 1